[Musique]
le porte flingue rivaux votre réaction
en fait que le bureau du sénat se soit
rangée à la demande de la commission d'
enquête et est transmis devant la
justice les cas d'alexis colère patrick
strzoda et du général lavernhe bien sûr
province en cradat ils sont bien là
c'est une autre histoire
la première réaction les que nous avons
affaire à une décision politique et un
procès politique dit-on dans vos rangs
c'est une décision politique
il faut que le bureau du sénat
l'assument comme telle elle ne repose
sur aucun fondement ni en fait ni en
droit au fond à l'issue de cette
procédure les masques tombent
on est dans un instrumentalisation à des
fins politiques d'une affaire sérieuse
grave qui a été qui a donné lieu à des
commissions d'enquêté une enquête
judiciaire et une enquête administrative
et ou à un moment où la haute assemblée
devrais je crois marquer l'importance de
la période
on a besoin d'unité nationale où on doit
faire fi des petits jeux politiciens
pour se rendre à l'intérêt général
je crois que la haute assemblée n'est
pas à ce rendez-vous nous on est
extrêmement calme extrêmement déterminé
extrêmement serein et on ne cédera rien
à cette instrumentalisation politique
les sénateurs répondre aux contre
pouvoirs je cite ce que dit bruno
retailleau ce matin et tant pis si
l'idée même de contre-pouvoir n'est pas
encore une notion familière pour
certains ils finiront par s'habituer
c'est politiquement bas et moralement
grave à nouveau le pays a besoin d'unité
nationale a besoin qu'on se rassemble
on se remonte les manches et que on
consacre le temps de travail à
l'assemblée nationale au sénat à
l'essentiel à ce qu'attendent nos
compatriotes à savoir qu'on trouve des
solutions à leurs problèmes et non pas
qu'on utilise une affaire dont j'ai dit
la gravité à des fins strictement
politique pour au fond régler des
comptes personnels
je crois que la haute assemblée mais
mieux que ça et j'ai cru comprendre que
des voix sur les bancs du sénat se sont
élevées depuis cette décision notamment
du côté des tiges puis c'est pour dire
que j'étais
pour le moins choqué de cette pratique
du pouvoir ce n'est pas la nôtre ce
n'est pas notre conception du rôle
important que joue le sénat dans nos
institutions
l'exécutif avait promis une réponse fois
parfois justement à la rapport de la
commission denquête qu'en est il ya du
set recours sur le fond l'elysée le fera
vous le savez mais elle a déjà eu
l'occasion de répondre à maintes
recommandations et des treize
recommandations qui ont été faites suite
à la commission
certaines ont d'ailleurs déjà été
engagées ce qui montre que le pouvoir
exécutif que l'elysée est attentif à ce
que le sénat peut dire et remarques le
sénat formule lorsqu il le fait avec
raison et avec mesure
la guerre n'est pas déclarée lorsqu il
le fait avec raison et avec mesure nous
ne sommes ni dans la raison ni dans la
mesure nous sommes dans le coup
politique très bien mais en tout cas
nous on a un seul horizon
l'intérêt général et l'unité du pays la
soukouk ou benjamin griveaux dame a
répondu à mes questions
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
je vous rappelle que notre séance et
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
sur notre site internet au nom du bureau
chacun sera attentif à respecter son
temps et au respect des uns et des
autres et je donne la parole à notre
collègue guillaume gontard pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
écologistes avaient la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
vendredi dernier et secrétaires d'état à
tata les poires sont manifestés avec les
civils les lycéens pour la sauvegarde du
climat
je me félicite que la france par le
biais de voûte de votre gouvernement
soit assise à la pointe du combat pour
la prévert préservation de
l'environnement
malheureusement le ministère de
l'économie et des finances n'a pas été
informé à temps de l'initiative
en effet dans la nuit de vendredi à
samedi juste avant l'ouverture de la
semaine sans pesticides
la majorité parlementaire avec la
bénédiction de bercy haddad adopté un
amendement au projet de loi pacte pour
repousser de trois ans à 2025
l'interdiction de la production en
france de pesticides pourtant interdit
d' usage dans l'union européenne
vous me rétorquerez que le sénat avait
purement et simplement supprimée cet air
de cette interdiction et vous aurez
raison
mais je note que le gouvernement
c'était alors pas opposé à ces
amendements rétrograde bilan des
opérations
la france va continuer à produire
pendant six ans des pesticides tellement
dangereux pour l'être humain tellement
nocif pour nos sols que l'union
européenne les a interdits sur son
territoire la même union européenne qui
tergiverse toujours sur le glyphosate
pourtant reconnu pour la deuxième fois
comme cancérigène par la justice
américaine
c'est dire le niveau de dangerosité des
produits en question
mais ce qui est dangereux pour les
européens ne l'est visiblement pas pour
le reste de l'humanité et la france va
pouvoir continuer a empoisonné pendant
six ans les agriculteurs des autres
continents alors que le président est
revenu sur sa promesse de sortie dit
glyphosate en trois ans le ministre de
l'agriculture confirmait pourtant dans
le même temps la dangerosité du produit
conséquence la politique du gouvernement
est parfaitement illisible
monsieur le premier ministre allez vous
enfin proposer une politique ambitieuse
de sortie des pesticides ou bien confier
cette mission à la fnsea et industriels
phyto phytopharmaceutiques comme le
laisse à penser la signature du
gouvernement au véritable contrat de
dupe dix contrats de solutions
merci pour vous répondre la parole est à
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
d'état ministre de transition écologique
et solidaire madame emmanuelle wargon
adam la ministre veut la parole monsieur
le président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur gontard
je vous remercie de cette question qui
leur permettent de revenir sur notre
ambition en matière de produits
phytosanitaires
cette ambition est forte nous nous
sommes engagés à diminuer l'utilisation
de ces produits de 50% d'ici à 2025
nous avons avancé avec la séparation de
la vente et du conseil qui sera
opérationnelle en 2019 et nous avons
augmenté la redevance pour pollutions
diffuses également opérationnel au 1er
janvier 2019 en matière de glyphosate et
vous le savez la france est le pays qui
a poussé l'union européenne à noeux
réautoriser cette substance que pour
cinq ans et nous pour 15 et non pour 15
ans et une en france nous avons pris
l'engagement de sortir du glyphosate en
trois ans cet engagement est aussi un
engagement d'accompagner toutes les
filières pour ne laisser aucune filière
au bord de la route et trouver des
solutions qui permettent une production
durable en france 110 feu that
ces solutions sont travaillés dans le
contraste solution avec l'aide fnsea
mais aussi
avec le monde de la recherche avec la
pca et avec tous les acteurs du monde de
l'agriculture
en ce qui concerne l'exportation le
récent vote de la loi pacte à
l'assemblée nationale a décalé à 2025
l'interdiction de production
d'utilisation et de stockage de tous les
produits y compris ceux qui ne sont pas
autorisés dans l'union européenne
nous sommes le seul pays de l'union
européenne à avoir pris cette décision
et cette interdiction
nous souhaitons que cette interdiction
soit partagée au niveau européen et
c'est l'une des raisons pour laquelle
nous avons accepté de décalage jusqu'à
2025 pour pouvoir porter ce projet à
bruxelles ce sujet à bruxelles et avoir
une politique communautaire offensive en
la matière nous souhaitons aussi
accompagner la filière
au lieu d'aller à une simple
interdiction nous allons accompagner les
producteurs pour que eux-mêmes changent
leurs pratiques et pour qu'ils puissent
proposer aux agriculteurs en dehors de
l'europe des solutions qui n'utilisent
plus ces produits
la politique que nous menons est bien
une politique ambitieuse de sortie mais
c'est aussi une politique de
transformation et nous accompagnons les
filières en ce sens merci la parole
non
monsieur ben ok
[Applaudissements]
quelle gloire monsieur boké la parole de
notre collègue jean marc todeschini
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adressait aussi à monsieur le premier
ministre
depuis le début de la crise sociale le
17 novembre dernier vous avez géré dans
l'improvisation absolue les réponses au
mouvement de contestation ainsi que la
sécurisation de ces manifestations
tout le monde a en tête les déclarations
du président de la république le 10
décembre
venant contredire les propos de ces
ministres y compris ceux du premier
ministre tenu quelques jours auparavant
le 10 décembre n'a été en fait que le
début d'une ère de contradictions et
d'improvisation qui trouve son paroxysme
avec l' annonce en conseil des ministres
du recours à l'armée pour les
manifestations de samedi prochain
le groupe socialiste avait déposé dès le
3 décembre
ces propositions pour sortir de la crise
cela passait par l' écoute et par un
dialogue sincère avec les français et
les élus nationaux et locaux
nous avions également condamné les
violences du 1er décembre comme les
violences dans toutes les manifestations
mais enfermé dans vos certitudes
vous n'avez toujours pas trouvé les
chemins pour sortir de la crise en
quatre mois
en laissant pourrir la situation au jour
sur l'affaiblissement progressif de la
contestation nous avait offert aux
casseurs un terrain propice pour leur
violence
vous êtes les seuls responsables de la
situation actuelle on décide d'appeler
les militaires vous prenez une très
grande responsabilité
vous devez expliquer aux français dans
quel cadre vous plantez employés des
militaires
quelles consignes leur ont été données
seront ils autorisés à le faire usage de
leurs armes en cas de débordements kelly
cette distinction est faite entre
délinquants nle nous avons besoin
d'éclaircissements suite aux
déclarations contradictoires de vos
ministres retirer des militaires de
l'opération sentinelles pour les mettre
sur le maintien de l'ordre c'est aussi
affaiblir la sécurité des français dans
les gares dans les aéroports sur les
marchés face à la menace terroriste
vous exposez enfin bruno militaire vous
prenez le risque de déstabiliser
l'institution qui est mobilisé et dédiée
depuis 2015 à la lutte contre le
terrorisme
voulez vous réellement prendre le risque
d'affaiblir le militaire en les
embarquant dans une polémique
s'il devait y avoir des blessés par
balles voire pire pour vos réformes la
parole et à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur que christophe castaner vous
avez la parole monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur je voudrais tout de suite vous
rassurer comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire ce matin à la préfecture de police
il est bien évidemment pas question que
les maudites les militaires de
sentinelle soit à la fois détournés de
leur fonction qui est celle de dans le
cadre de sentinelle de protéger les
français du risque terroriste de
protéger les français face à des tueries
de masse est d'être présent partout
partout en france et dans paris en
particulier il n'est pas question
d'utiliser les forces armées les
militaires pour gérer l'ordre public
tout simplement parce que et vous l'avez
dit dans votre question et vous avez une
expérience de ministre au ministère des
armées vous le savez ils ont de très
grandes qualités mais ils ne sont pas
formés ni équipés pour gérer l'ordre
public et donc samedi prochain
comme pour les samedis passé depuis le
mouvement le début du mouvement des
jeunes
mais comme depuis 2015 les militaires de
sentinelle seront là pour épauler les
français dans l'enjeu de sécurité ils
seront là pour épauler aussi nos forces
de sécurité sur ces sujets là mais pas
pour gérer l'ordre public
à certains endroits ils se substitueront
ils se substitueront pour garder des
bâtiments qui ne seront pas exposés à un
risque de manifestations
ils se substitueront pour libérer des
forces qui elles seront des forces de
police ou deux gendarmes qui elles
seront mobilisés pour assurer la gestion
de l'ordre public
voilà monsieur le sénateur mesdames
messieurs sénateurs j'ai vu la polémique
suite à l'information qui avait été
communiquée par le porte parole qui
donnait juste l'information que oui les
militaires de sentinelle seraient
mobilisés samedi prochain comme ils
l'ont été systématiquement depuis le 17
novembre il ya eu un emballement cet
emballement peut-être clos immédiatement
et je tiens à vous rassurer
merci beaucoup merci
monsieur le ministre n'a pas relève
notre collègue emmanuel capus pour le
groupe les indépendants république et
territoires ddt avez la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
148 coups de fouet trente trois ans de
prison
pas pour avoir tabassé un policier sur
les champs-elysées pas pour avoir tenté
de brûler vive une femme et son bébé
non n'en déplaise aux révolutionnaires
de plateaux télé qui samedi après samedi
proclame avec des trémolos dans la voix
que nous vivons dans une dictature
je ne parle pas de la france non mes
chers collègues 148 coups de fouet et 33
ans de prison c'est la condamnation le 8
mars dernier de nasrin sotoudeh avocate
iranienne par un tribunal de téhéran
son crime mes chers collègues avoir
défendu ses clientes des femmes qui
retiraient leur voile en public
pire avoir contesté publiquement le port
obligatoire du voile nasrin sotoudeh
défenseurs des droits des femmes
lauréate du prix sakharov 2012 décerné
par le parlement européen la france
monsieur le ministre doit défendre et
soutenir ou qu'ils se trouvent celles et
ceux qui comme elles mettent en jeu leur
propre sécurité pour défendre les
libertés fondamentales pour défendre les
valeurs universelles qui fondent notre
république et au premier rang d'entre
elles la liberté religieuse
l'égalité entre les hommes et les femmes
et les droits de la défense
nasrin sotoudeh a renoncé à faire appel
car elle croit sa cause perdue mais de
très nombreux soutiens de par le monde
refuse de s'y résoudre
comme en témoigne en france et pétitions
qui se multiplient monsieur le ministre
ma question est très simple croyez-vous
également sa cause perdue monsieur le
ministre
la france va-t-elle intensifier son
action afin d'obtenir la libération
immédiate et inconditionnelle de nasrin
sotoudeh
[Applaudissements]
pour vous répondre la parole est aux
ministres de l'europe des affaires
étrangères monsieur jean yves le drian
au monsieur le sénateur le cas de madame
sotoudeh suscite l'indignation
l'indignation à travers le monde et vous
en avez été tout à l'instant le porte
parole
et cette indignation le gouvernement la
partage pleinement d'abord parce qu'elle
a été condamnée dans des conditions à
urt e-sante ensuite parce qu'elle a eu
des peines lourdes que vous avez
évoquées y compris des coups de fouet
ensuite parce qu'il s'agit d'une avocate
condamné comme avocate
il s'agit d'une femme condamnée pour
avoir défendu les droits des femmes et
en particulier celles qui comptent s en
iran l'obligation du voile islamique
et enfin parce que madame se souviennent
est un symbole son engagement lui a valu
en 2012 le prix sakharov du parlement
européen
il lui a valu aussi cet engagement des
arrestations d emprisonnement des
pressions c'est pourquoi comme vous le
savez le présent de la république a
publiquement appelé à l'occasion de la
remise du premier prix au simone veil à
sa libération
c'est pourquoi le président n'aurait
plus qu'à souhaiter dans le cadre du g7
de la faire symboliquement membre du
conseil consultatif pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes et genre dirais
cela à la tribune des nations unies
puisque vous le savez la france préside
le conseil de sécurité en ce moment et
je l'assurait la semaine prochaine alors
on fait des efforts considérables
ces derniers mois avec les rangs pour
préserver l'accord nucléaire en dépit de
décrets du retrait américain
nous le faisons parce que nous honorons
nos signatures mais l'iran doit aussi
respecter ses engagements et en
particulier ceux du pacte international
relatif aux droits civils et politiques
et notre souci de préserver l'accord de
vienne n'est pas un blanc-seing accordé
à l'iran et certainement pas en matière
des droits de l'homme c'est pourquoi
nous
ont tout pour obtenir la libération de
madame sotoudeh merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
philippe dominati pour le groupe l'est
républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur car
le limogeage justifier du préfet de
police est un événement sans précédent
sous l'histoire la vème république le
sénat n'a pas manqué d'alerter le
gouvernement il ya eu la commission
denquête de mon collègue grosdidier la
loi anti-casseurs du président
retailleau à deux reprises le budget
pourtant régalien a été rejetée par
cette assemblée le budget du ministère
de l'intérieur
il ya eu une demande de la cour des
comptes j'ai moi même proposé un rapport
sur la commission des finances sur le
renseignement intérieur et sur la
préfecture de police
malgré cela quatre mois après le saccage
de l'arc de triomphe et les champs
elysées sont en ruine la france veut
propager l'image de la paix en afrique
en syrie mais elle est incapable de
l'assuré au parisien à quelques
encablures de l'elysée alors ma question
est simple monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur dans quels délais vous vous
engager vis-à-vis de vos hommes
vis-à-vis des parisiens vis-à-vis des
français à rétablir l'ordre
toro répondre la parole et au secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur laurent du lez
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur philippe dominati
vous évoquez donc les d'abord le
limogeage du préfet de police ensuite
les incidents graves très graves qu'il y
a eu samedi dernier effectivement sur
les champs-elysées vous évoquez quatre
mois de tension extrême je vais vous
rappeler que et vous avez raison de
rappeler les incidents très graves qu'il
y a eu le 1er décembre sur les champs
elysées qui nous avaient conduits avec
christophe castaner immédiatement et de
manière totalement inédite à revoir
totalement la doctrine de gestion de
l'ordre public en donnant comme nous le
demandaient les policiers comme nous le
demander les policiers les organisations
syndicales de policiers beaucoup de
mobilité de réactivité de capacité
d'interpellation et de déconcentration
des pouvoirs de décision et samedi après
samedi pardon mais vous ne pouvez pas
parler de cas au samedi après samedi il
y a eu le 8 décembre il y a eu dès
samedi où nous avons évité tant
d'exactions temps de pillage et
peut-être même monsieur le sénateur
philippe dominati peut-être même des
morts vous savez que c'est un curseur
important en matière de gestion de leur
public et c'était partout vrai à paris
comme en province
alors oui samedi samedi dernier il y a
eu un vrai dysfonctionnement car cette
doctrine réactive d'interpellations elle
n'a pas été mise en ordre en oeuvre
pardon alors même que nous avions donné
des instructions extrêmement précises
avec christophe castaner en ce sens et
c'est ce qui nous a conduit à renforcer
encore plus sa doctrine et comme vous le
savez le premier ministre a annoncé
désormais tout attroupement qui risquent
de présenter un caractère volent violent
sera immédiatement dispersés et seront
prises à l'appui de ces mesures
des arrêtés d'interdiction qui seront
conclus avec chacun des maires concernés
et qui permettront de venir appuyer ces
mesures de dispersion d'attroupement
mais permettez moi d'insister vous le
savez très bien monsieur le sénateur
philippe de lunettes il vous savez très
bien qu'à paris des débordements matière
d'ordre public il y en a eu plein
d'autres et sous d'autres quinquennat
sous d'autres quinquennat et il faut
toujours savoir apprécier ces questions
d'ordre public et se lancer haut
fonctionnaire spécialiste des questions
de sécurité qui vous le dit
avec beaucoup de modestie et d'humilité
car entre 2007 et 2012 il ya aussi
beaucoup d'incidents en matière d'ordre
public
monsieur dominati tout d'abord je
voudrais faire une observation
en préambule le fait monsieur neige que
vous me répondiez vous attire la
sympathie de cet hémicycle
car nous avons tous compris que vous
étés le prochain fusible ma question
s'adresser au ministre de l'intérieur le
ministre de l'intérieur qui a peu de
temps était le chef d'un parti politique
qui dans 18 circonscriptions à paris et
représentée par quatorze parlementaires
et on dirait pourtant que le
gouvernement est sourd il entend pas
l'exaspération des parisiens il entend
pas le désespoir de ceux qui ne peuvent
plus travailler
ils n'entendent pas partout même à la
périphérie
le fait que le tourisme l'activité
économique la justice la délinquance
l'antisémitisme explose parce que vous
n'arrivez pas à résoudre un problème et
à paris les parisiens souffrent déjà des
difficultés provoquées pour la brûlure
mais en réalité nous sommes nous ici
victime de la double peine la
considération du gouvernement
l'incompétence de la mairie et c'est en
cela que je voulais exprimer quelque
chose
obéniche de l'intérieur si les copies
merci
la parole est à madame catherine
fournier pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole madame la
présidente
[Applaudissements]
oui merci monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur gérald darmanin ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
mon propos portent sur la grève des
douaniers déclenché le 4 mars dernier
sur fond de bréxent it
les effets se sont vite fait sentir des
perturbations importantes en gare du
nord sur les eurostar et un blocage
complet de calais calais pris en otage
une fois de plus une fois de trop
ce mouvement de contestation de dure
depuis près de trois semaines des
contrôles zélés sporadiques effectué au
port et au tunnel sous la manche blocs
de manière insupportable tout
déplacement normale sur les principaux
axes de circulation
les conséquences pour le territoire sont
désastreuses je vous les énumère des
camions à l'arrêt des heures sur les
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence jusqu'à 9
heures des chauffeurs sans information
sans ravitaillement sans sanitaires des
résidents qui se voit bloqué à des
entrées ou des sorties d'autoroute fermé
et nos prêts signaler sans information
sans indication de déviation sans
filtrage les salariés accusent des
retards sur leur lieu de travail les
artisans des difficultés à se rendre sur
leurs chantiers
les commerces sont désertés les sociétés
sont en attente de leur livraison et les
transporteurs locaux exemple est excédé
c'est une perturbation de trop qui sème
la colère
monsieur le ministre nous avons appris
au travers des de la crise des gilet
jaune que laisser pourrir une situation
c'est semer et accentuer le
mécontentement qu'elle est est un port
de combes est un point de convergence
routier qui fonctionne à flux tendu on
doit le gérer dans son exception
l'activité économique du calaisis et le
trafic transmanche sont donc suspendus
au piétinement des négociations entre
l'état et ses agents nous avons besoin
d'un signal fort
pouvez vous présenter les moyens que
vous comptez mettre en place pour
arrêter ce mouvement de grève
merci pour vos réponses
la parole est aux secrétaires d'état ont
fait des actions des contenus que
monsieur olivier dussopt up la parole
monsieur le ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice tournée vous nous interroger
sur le mouvement de grève des douaniers
avec deux points qui concentre le plus
de difficultés la gare du nord à paris
vous avez évoqué et la région de calais
avec des conséquences économiques que
vous avez rappelé et qui pénalise le
territoire nous avons apporté des
réponses aux douaniers nous avons
apporté des réponses dans le cadre de la
préparation du bric site
avant ce mouvement avec la programmation
et dès 2019 la création de plusieurs
centaines de postes douaniers pour faire
face aux briques site dans des
conditions correctes sans avoir à
retirer des forces douanières dans
d'autres points du territoire depuis le
début de ce mouvement
les douaniers les organisations
syndicales qu'il représente ont été
reçus par le ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics gérald darmanin et à
plusieurs reprises par le directeur
général des douanes
nous leur avons proposé deux types de
mesures une mesure immédiate qui
consiste en une revalorisation salariale
de plus de 50 euros nets à compter du
1er juillet dont les 17000 douaniers et
cela représente un engagement de 14
millions d'euros
nous leur avons aussi proposé d'ouvrir
des chantiers complémentaires sur la
question des conditions de travail c'est
sur la base des propositions nous avons
formulé que les discussions se
poursuivent mais je tiens à dire devant
vous que dans l'attenté de
l'aboutissement de ces discussions
il est impératif que le trafic puisse
reprendre dans de bonnes conditions et
nous avons donné consigne instruction et
gendarmes anaya veillait tout
particulièrement que les sanctions
soient prises contre les actions qui
viennent contrevenir au bon
fonctionnement des infrastructures de
l'économie et de la circulation libre
des marchandises comme des personnes je
saisis l'occasion de votre question pour
ajouter deux choses la première pour
dire que les perturbations qui sont le
fruit de ce mouvement de grève n'ont
absolument rien à voir avec la réalité
projeté après le break site pour une
raison toute simple les contrôles
sporadiques et les mouvements que vous
évoquez contrôles concernent des sorties
du territoire alors que dans le cas du
break sic nous aurons à contrôler les
entrées ce qui démontre l'absence totale
de lien avec la réalité projeté la
deuxième chose que je veux souligner
devant vous et devant toute votre
assemblée c'est le fait que
le premier ministre nous a demandé à
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
de préparer toutes les hypothèses de
briques sites y compris un break it sans
accord c'est dans ce cadre que nous
travaillons nous comptons sur les
douaniers mais nous comptons sur
l'engagement pour mettre fin à ces
perturbations
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à notre collègue bernard but pour le
groupe de la république en marche avait
la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès de la
ministre des solidarités de la santé il
ya quelques jours à peine le 8 mars dans
une communion quasiment unanime nous
célébrions la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
à cette occasion nombre d'entre nous
rend bien hommage à ces femmes qui
emmenait des combats pour que leurs
droits avance au fil des années je pense
ici plus particulièrement à celles qui
étaient à votre place madame la ministre
simone veil
je pense à elles et au combat courageux
qu'elle a menées en 1976 à contre
courant de sa famille politique à
l'époque pour que les femmes puissent
disposer de leur corps et choisir de
donner la vie ou pas parce qu'un enfant
tu n' était pas leur choix grâce à
simone veil le droit à l'avortement
était enfin illégal en france madame la
ministre
ce droit fondamental des femmes de
disposer de leur corps est en danger pas
uniquement aux états unis où des
intégristes anti-avortement s'enchaînent
sur les grilles des cliniques pratiquant
cet acte médical
ce danger est aussi présent ici en
france et qui plus est commandité par
des médecins
comment est il possible que le syndicat
national des gynécologues-obstétriciens
par la voix de son président puisse
menacer le droit à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse pour faire
pression sur vous madame et sur votre
gouvernement
ce syndicat a menacé d'une grève des ivg
s'ils n'obtenaient pas satisfaction sur
les dédommagements demandés dans des
erreurs médicales manifeste quelle est
leur déontologie médicale pour oser une
telle menace
le président du syndicat national des
gynécologues-obstétriciens dans n'est
malheureusement pas son premier acte
anti ivg
il ya quelques mois à peine en septembre
dernier il déclarait publiquement qu'ils
considéraient l'avortement comme un
crime
se défendant peu après d'affiché là une
conviction personnelle
madame la ministre aujourd'hui je suis
et nous sommes tous partagé entre
la colère est la honte de tels
comportements pour les représentants
d'une corporation médicale
alors madame la ministre je vous
remercie de nous expliquer quel est
votre positionnement face à de tels
agissements et comment vous pouvez nous
assurer que vous serez la garante d'un
droit fondamental des femmes le droit
l'ibg et de choisir ainsi d'avoir ou non
un enfant pour vous raccorder par les
cas la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre des solidarités et de la
chanter l'ampli du golfe et la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames la
sénatrice mais c'est le sénateur
monsieur le sénateur au préalable je
prie d'excuser l'absence de la ministre
mais amusant étant retenu à l'assemblée
nationale sur le pour l'examen du projet
de loi santé monsieur le sénateur comme
vous nous jugeons ce communiqué du
syndicat national des gynécologues et
obstétriciens de france totalement
scandaleux ils menacent d'un refus
spécifique d'un acte et pas n'importe
lequel le refus de l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse est un acte
militant
un acte signifiant ce n'est pas digne
d'un syndicat dès que la ministre des
solidarités et de la santé en a eu
connaissance à la dénoncer le caractère
inadmissible de ces menaces destinées à
se faire entendre
vous l'avez dit ces menaces vont à
l'encontre du respect inconditionnel du
droit à l'image est garantie d'un autre
pays
ces nouvelles déclarations sont
inacceptables de la part d'un syndicat
qui entend représenter les gynécologues
obstétriciens obstétriciens cette
profession doit être plus près des
souffrances des femmes est d'accompagner
ces dernières notamment dans ce moment
très difficile et très douloureux
qu'elle interruption volontaire de
grossesse mais sachez en aucun cas
qu'une telle prise en otage des femmes
ne servira de levier de négociation au
sein de notre ministère en aucun cas une
telle prise d'otage des femmes ne peut
non plus servir à la médiation d'un
dossier en tout cas si médiation il ya
eu elle ne met pas à l'honneur ce
syndicat ni les professionnels qu'ils
représentent et je le regrette nous le
regrettons vivement
je vous remercie merci la parole et
un autre collègue et rigole pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à la
ministre en charge de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales
madame la ministre dans son rapport
annuel publié la semaine dernière le
défenseur des droits met en garde les
états contre le risque de rupture entre
les services publics et les usagers en
94 % des réclamations qui lui ont été
adressés portait en effet sur cette
relation des usagers avec les services
publics
parmi les premiers sujets de
préoccupation figurent la
dématérialisation des procédures
administratives que le gouvernement
souhaite achever en 2022
d'une part cette dématérialisation soul
à de nombreuses difficultés d'ordre
technique et organisationnel il n'ya
qu'à se pencher sur la délivrance des
titres sécurisés dans les transports
pour voir que les exemples de
défaillances sont nombreux d'autre part
comme l'a très justement rappelé mon
collègue jean yves roux en janvier la
dématérialisation des services publics
nécessite une large couverture internet
un bon équipement des ménages et une
maîtrise de l'outil informatique
or plusieurs centaines de communes n'ont
toujours pas accès internet et 13
millions de français sont encore en
difficulté avec le numérique
sans compter le coût de l'équipement
informatique que l'on fait bien sûr
peser sur les ménages
le numérique est un facilitateur
indéniable dans de nombreux domaines
il n'est pas question de remettre en
cause un tel progrès mais dans cette
phase de transition il est essentiel de
renforcer l'accompagnement et
l'inclusion numérique car une absence de
l'état dans les territoires peu amplifié
les difficultés d'accès au droit est le
sentiment d'injustice et d'abandon
notamment en zone rurale où les services
de proximité sont en déshérence
il existe une fracture territoriale de
plus en plus profonde entre la france
des métropoles et la france des
territoires qui cumule toutes les
difficultés déserts médicaux suppression
de services dans les hôpitaux la justice
fermetures d'écoles et de commerces
hausse du coût de la vie et des
transports en commun est inexistant
ajoutez à cela la disparition des
services publics et vous obtenez un
terreau fertile pour les extrêmes
aussi madame la ministre je souhaite
savoir quelles sont les actions que le
gouvernement va mettre en oeuvre
pour reconnecter les territoires et
rendre effective la promesse
républicaine d'égalité d'accès au droit
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à madame la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires des relations
avec les collectivités territoriales
madame jacqueline gourault avez la
parole merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur eric gold
vous avez raison et je partage votre
diagnostic si la dématérialisation de
certains services est indispensable pour
répondre aux besoins de nos concitoyens
nous devons être très attentifs aussi à
la situation des 13 millions de
personnes qui ressentent des difficultés
dans l' usage du numérique
pour cela le gouvernement agit dans
trois directions d'abord pour renforcer
la présence du numérique sur le
territoire avec un engagement de plus de
3 milliards du gouvernement aidé en cela
par les collectivités territoriales qui
agissent aussi sur les territoires pour
développer l'accès au très haut débit
d'ici 2022
je ne parle pas aussi du réseau mobile
qui grâce à l'accord historique que
julien de normandie a passé avec eux
permet un très bon développement
territorial mais il faut accompagner et
la mise en place de mesures fortes
d'inclusion numérique tant avec le
guichet cohésion numérique des
territoires qui se traduit par un
soutien financier jusqu'à 150 euros pour
l'installation d'équipements et puis il
ya également le pass numérique qui
permet d'accéder en compétences avec des
personnes qui sont qui ont besoin d'être
formés qui sont les moins à l'aise avec
le numérique et enfin troisièmement avec
un accompagnement humain nécessaire de
nos concitoyens qui sont très éloignées
si je fais dire du numérique au milieu
je dirais ou à l'intérieur des maisons
notamment de service public
il y en a mille quatre cent sur le
territoire et il y à aussi la présence
dans les sous-préfectures et dans les
préfectures de médiateur numérique
pourrait
dès les usagers vous pouvez être assuré
monsieur le sénateur de la détermination
du gouvernement à améliorer bien sûr la
présence numérique sur le territoire
mais aussi accompagner donc la mise en
oeuvre de l'accompagnement des personnes
qui sont loin du numérique
merci madame la ministre je vais donner
la parole de notre collègue monique
lubin pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
ma question s'adresse et initialement à
monsieur le premier ministre depuis
quelques jours nous assistons à une
véritable cacophonie émanant de votre
gouvernement sur fond de réforme des
retraites alors que la concertation sur
cette réforme touche à sa fin alors que
depuis le début il a toujours été établi
que le recul de l'âge de la retraite
n'était pas à l'ordre du jour
voilà que vos ministres jouent des
partitions bien différente
c'est tout d'abord madame la ministre
des solidarités qui ouvre le débat en
affirmant que le sujet n'est pas tabou
s'en suit de manière fort légitime
l'étonnement du haut-commissaire pour
qui cette question ne faisait pas partie
du cahier des charges si j'ose
m'exprimer ainsi
après un rétropédalage de madame la
ministre des solidarités c'est au tour
du porte parole du gouvernement de
réaffirmer que le recul de l'âge de
départ à la retraite faisait partie
intégrante de la concertation mais
finalement s'agit-il d'une cacophonie ou
bien d'un jeu de rôles savamment
orchestré monsieur le premier ministre a
affimé affirmé hier qu'il ne reviendrait
pas sur l'âge de départ à la retraite
tout en précisant qu'il faudrait
néanmoins s'interroger sur un
allongement de la durée du travail
propos repris peu ou prou ce matin même
par le haut commissaire tout cela n'est
que confusion
ma question est donc simple existe-t-il
dans votre gouvernement une volonté
clairement établie et partager de
maintenir ce droit à nos yeux non
négociable notamment pour ceux qui sont
entrés tôt dans le monde du travail
et qui exercent le plus souvent des
métiers pénibles droit qui devra être
assorti bien évidemment d'un niveau de
pension suffisant pour vous répondre je
vais donner la parole je signale
simplement corps soit mort à
l'initiative de la commission des
affaires sociales un débat avec entre
les partenaires sociaux et le haut
commissaire se déroule dans notre salle
clemenceau monsieur le ministre auprès
du premier ministre chargé des relations
avec le parlement monsieur fesneau pour
vous répondre merci monsieur le
président mais merci mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
cette question me permets de rappeler
les propos tenus
mais
j'aimerais pouvoir répondre à votre
collègue si ça ne vous dérange pas cette
question me permets de rappeler cette
personne question madame la sénatrice me
permets de rappeler les propos tenus par
le premier ministre hier devant
l'assemblée nationale à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
l'objectif de la réforme des retraites
c'est construire l'objectif de larges
comme s'il vous plaît l'objectif de la
réforme de retraites c'est construire un
système de retraites plus lisible plus
juste plus solidaire dans lequel un euro
cote ici vous n'écoutez pas c'est votre
choix mais je pense que d'autres peuvent
être intéressés par la réponse du
sénateur donne les mêmes droits à tous
c'est le mandat qui a été confié à jean
paul delevoye
comme l'a rappelé le premier ministre
hier ce mandat n'a pas changé et ne
porte pas sur la question paramétrique
de l'âge minimal de départ à la retraite
dans le même temps regardons les faits
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie est
une réalité que nous devons regarder en
face il ya un million cinq de personnes
de plus de 85 ans aujourd'hui elles
seront cinq millions en 2050
on parle d'un changement démographique
comme il y en a peu dans l'histoire des
sociétés
le vieillissement la population qu'il
induit représente un défi majeur pour
notre protection sociale et son
financement notamment pour notre système
de santé de prise en charge des
personnes âgées dépendantes
il va demander des déployer des moyens
financiers considérables pour le feu la
prise en charge de la dépendance
mais c'est le reste à charge des
familles améliorer les conditions de
travail dans les ehpad mieux prendre en
compte la charge à domicile c'est des
subtiles que nous pouvons partager et
pour financer ses besoins nouveaux nous
n'augmenterons pas les impôts
la question de la prise en compte de
l'espérance de vie est un paramètre
majeur de la pérennité de notre système
de protection sociale
cette question a été ouverte dans le
cadre du grand débat national et elle
n'est pas fermée madame la sénatrice il
le semble qu'il ne faut pas trancher
cette question avant de l'avoir posée
belga donc les choses me paraissent
décidément clair nous sommes toujours
dans la confusion
nous ne pourrons pas faire payer la
solidarité pour la dépendance par les
gens qui travaillent longtemps sur des
métiers pénibles et qui commence très
tôt ça ne sera pas possible
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue christine bonfanti-dossat pour
le groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresser au premier ministre
[Musique]
or est aurait-on pu éviter aurait-on pu
éviter les scènes de violence les scènes
de pillage commises par les casseurs ce
samedi lors du 18e acte de mobilisation
des gilet jaune
y at-il eu des défaillances et un manque
d'anticipation
faut-il appeler cela de l'amateurisme
toutes ces questions les français se les
posent ils ne veulent plus débattre ils
ne veulent plus de discours plus de
formules médiatique
ils veulent des actes nous ne sommes
plus dans le cadre d'un maintien de
l'ordre classique à la suite des
événements du 1er octobre à l'arc de
triomphe nous attendions déjà de votre
part des actes forts
or vous n'avez rien fait de plus et ne
rien faire de plus c'est laisser faire
aujourd'hui aucune mesure politique ne
pourra apaiser durablement la situation
ce n'est pas vos incantations qui
calmeront le pays encore au moins le
recours à l'armée monsieur le ministre
votre en même temps dans le domaine
régalien est un véritable échec
il faut adopter la seule politique qui
vaille celle de la fermeté la hauteur de
la violence celle que le sénat vous
propose depuis le mois de juin
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
me dire à combien se chiffrent les
dégâts qui va les payer
les français qui verront leurs
cotisations d'assurance augmentent et où
êtes-vous enfin près de fer impayés les
casseurs et puis je vous rappelle ma
question s'adresser au premier ministre
êtes vous sûr
êtes vous sûr êtes vous sûr qu'avec un
tel discrédit
le ministre de l'intérieur est encore à
mesure de poursuivre sa mission
place beauvau merci la parole et au
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'intérieur
messieurs le ronin elle avait la parole
monsieur le ministre
allez dis monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice christine bonfanti je suis de
remarques par rapport à votre question
d'abord je suis très heureux de
constater que maintenant vous nous
expliquer que ce à quoi nous avons à
faire face depuis le 17 novembre
ça n'est pas du maintien de l'ordre
classique ce n'est pas toujours ce qui a
été dit sur ces bancs je vous le
rappelle depuis le début nous disons de
ce mouvement il étant empreint d'une
très grande violence d'une remise en
cause de nos institutions nous avons
souvent parlé sédition je suis heureux
que depuis quelques semaines seulement
vous nous rejoignez sur cette thématique
quelques semaines seulement mais nous
n'avons pas attendu que vous évoluez
dans l'analyse des faits et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous sommes ici
et que nous gérons nous ce problème
c'est ce que les français souhaitaient
tous soyons là en gestion d après le
premier descend d après le 1er décembre
nous avons fait évoluer la doctrine nous
avons fait évoluer cette doctrine nous
n'avons pas rien fait les organisations
syndicales que nous voyons régulièrement
avec christophe castaner nous ont
remerciés de cette évolution de doctrine
ils nous ont remerciés de cette latitude
qui leur a été laissé dans
l'interpellation dans la possibilité
d'agir
dix mille personnes interpellées 1800
personnes placées qui ont été jugés 40%
de peines de prison ferme comment osez
vous dire que nous ne faisons rien
comment osez vous dire que nous ne
faisons rien et nous allons continuer et
nous serons présents ce samedi à nouveau
samedi dernier nos instructions n'ont
pas été appliquées et c'est très grave
c'est un dysfonctionnement majeur et ce
sont les policiers eux mêmes qui se sont
adressés à nous pour se plaindre de ce
qu'ils n'avaient pas reçu les bonne
instruction
alors samedi nous continuerons à assurer
l'ordre républicain nous considérons
nous continuerons à protéger la
république parce que c'est ce que nous
faisons et je vous demande simplement
vous interrogez vous que feriez vous à
notre place que s'est il passé entre
2007 et 2012
que s'est il passé entre 2012 et 2017 il
y a eu beaucoup d'incidents d'ordre
public
il y a eu beaucoup d'incidents d'ordre
public et nous nous avons pris des
mesures à la fois législatives et des
mesures opérationnelles qui vise à y
mettre un terme
et dès demain d2d samedi tous les
attroupements qui se réuniront qui
comporteront des casseurs seront comme
nous l'avons annoncé immédiatement
dispersés merci
eh bien si
la parole est à notre collègue libéraux
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur à
l'heure où les français sont indignés de
voir leur pays exemple d'autres victimes
oubliées de tous subissent les dommages
collatéraux de cette crise
je veux parler ici des familles des
forces de l'ordre de leurs épouses leurs
époux de leurs enfants
depuis le début de l'année on dénombre
24 suicides dont 19 au sein de la police
nationale des femmes et des hommes qui
s'étaient engagés pour protéger les
français depuis des mois la police
essaie de maintenir l'ordre dans des
manifestations chaque fois plus
violentes
les familles de ces derniers subissent
au quotidien via les réseaux sociaux une
agressivité telles qu'elles demandent à
leurs enfants de ne plus dire que leurs
parents et policiers aux gendarmes en
plus dans les cours d'école se rejoue
les scènes vues sur les écrans entre les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants
comment expliquer dès lors un enfant
qu'il n'ait pas honte d'avoir un parent
qui a choisi cet engagement
l'association femmes des forces de
l'ordre en colère de ma région
bien avant les manifestations des gilets
jaunes avaient alerté le président de la
république sur les conditions de travail
de leurs époux ce dernier leur avait
répondu en août 2017 quelles seraient
reçus par le ministre de l'intérieur
or depuis le remaniement ministériel
rien n'a été mis en oeuvre pour entendre
leurs voix que comptez vous faire
monsieur le ministre pour protéger ces
familles pourriez vous honorer les
promesses de notre président et prendre
le temps de recevoir et d'écouter ces
femmes
pour vos réformes parole et à monsieur
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs
je crois que c'est la deuxième question
à laquelle je réponds et je crois je le
rappelle a quelques-uns que nous aurons
passé trois heures au sein de la
commission des lois a abordé le sujet
global de l'ordre public était un sujet
qui doit effectivement impliqués de
prendre le temps de l'action et puis il
y a les situations humaines vécu vous
avez abordé madame la sénatrice b
suicide
c'est un métier extrêmement difficile
avec des pressions fortes et c'est un
métier armée très régulièrement nous
avons effectivement des drames
épouvantables et je peux vous dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu une rencontre avec les
syndicats avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux avec les états
majors où je n'ai pas abordé la question
de la prévention du suicide dans cette
question nous la connaissons tous mais
les particules en forte difficile
inhumaines à traiter au sein des
effectifs de police comme de la
gendarmerie et sur lesquels nous devons
être très mobilisés parce que ils
subissent cette violence du quotidien il
suivit cette mise en cause permanente
et puis il ya les familles et vous avez
raison d'aborder effectivement cela
sachez madame la sénatrice que nous
mettons en place de façon systématique
et la gendarmerie nationale est par
exemple un modèle qui est reproduit dans
beaucoup d'entreprises privées nous
mettons en place de façon systématique
1a commun ou psychologique médical et
social pour les proches
chaque fois qu'il y à des attaques ou
des drames nous mobilisons aussi des
moyens financiers pour sécuriser
sécuriser la vie le quotidien de nos
forces et en particulier de nos
gendarmes qui vivent vous le savez dans
des lieux regroupés il est évident que
nous devons aussi les protéger quand à
l'anonymat non pas pour que ce qu'il
pourrait faire soit caché mais tout
simplement pour que leur quotidien et
leurs interventions dans des procédures
judiciaires puissent souffert se faire
aussi sous le couvert de l'anonymat est
ce la raison pour laquelle j'ai signé un
arrêté le 12 février dernier qui étend
la liste des services dont les agents ne
peuvent voir leur identité dévoilée
notamment dans les médias parce qu'il
faut protéger protéger tout le monde
enfin madame la sénatrice vous m'invitez
a rencontré une association que je ne
connais pas territoriale par contre je
peux vous dire que le dialogue avec les
organisations sociales et permanent à 17
heures je recevrai avec laurent nunez la
totalité des organisations syndicales et
je peux vous dire que depuis nous
cessons de le faire et que les
conditions de travail de nos gardiens de
la paix notamment à travers l'accord que
nous avons signé aux manoeuvres au mode
décembre sont fortement améliorés et
c'est nécessaire et juste merci madame
alain perreault tels que seconde
quelques secondes simplement monsieur le
ministre vous nous avez dit cette
semaine que vous envisagez un plan de
recrutement dans la police alors changer
l'image négative que cette fonction
inspire à certains et redonner à ces
femmes et ces hommes engagés respect et
dignité
merci d'abord notre collègue arnaud de
belenet pour le groupe de la république
en bas merci vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres collègues
j'aurais aimé poser une question premier
ministre pour le plaisir pour le plaisir
d'entendre pour la troisième fois son
nom scandé sur les bancs socialistes
c'est suffisamment rare et agréable de
d'entendre le premier ministre a clamé
sur les bancs socialistes néanmoins et
j'en suis très heureux ma question
s'adresse à et madame la ministre
emmanuelle wargon la jeunesse chers
collègues manifesté pour le climat
donnant aux générations qui la précède
est la nôtre en particulier une leçon de
sagesse et de clairvoyance au moment
même aux mets au même moment l'un 110e
déclaré à bord de l' eric l'america
grande et sous pavillon italien avec à
bord des milliers de fioul de propulsion
et des containers de manière de matières
dangereuses
l'europe nous accompagne avec notamment
l'intervention des bâtiments de sa
flotte pour intervenir de manière
curative sur la pollution est en lien
avec françoise cartron ma question porte
bien sûr sur les mesures prises en
réaction à la pollution pour protéger
nos côtes et nos zoo alors certes et
c'est l'occasion de le saluer depuis la
catastrophe de l'erika
l'union européenne a accru la sécurité
maritime par des mesures
et des règles de prévention d'adoption
des paquets et ricard 1 2 et 3 et l'
agence européenne sont des outils
efficaces
ainsi le grand d amérique avait fait
l'objet en 2010 d'un certain nombre de
contrôles qui avait relevé 35
déficiences techniques dont
quelques-unes 14 sur la sécurité
incendie
mais en octobre dernier à hambourg les
contrôles ne relevait plus que 3 défaut
de règlement dont l'un concernait la
rétention du fuel à bord alors les
principaux risques liés au transport
maritime sont endiguée grâce à l'europe
qui nous a protégés
néanmoins une partie du chemin reste à
faire alors madame la ministre
si l'amérique à grande et nous montre
qu'en ce domaine aussi
nous avons besoin d'europe nous avons
besoin de régulation
ma question porte simplement sur la
façon dont la france entend plaider pour
un renforcement de la réglementation
relative au transport maritime auprès de
nos partenaires
bien qu'on vous répondre la parole et
collations quaker et corps auprès du
ministre de la transition écologique et
solidaire
madame la ministre monsieur le président
du sénat mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur arnaud de
belenet vous l'avez dit le naufrage de
grandes des amériques est une
catastrophe environnementale face à
laquelle le ministère de la transition
écologique et solidaire a réagi
immédiatement
il s'agit d'un navire italien en
provenance de hambourg à destination de
casablanca qui a fait naufrage à 320 km
des côtes à 4500 mètres de profondeur le
ministre d'état françois de rugy s'est
rendu sur place dès jeudi dernier
poursuivre pour assurer heure par heure
le suivi de l'incident mettre en place
les opérations de secours pour saluer le
sauvetage des vingt-sept personnes à
bord et pour renforcer l'engagement
d'une lutte contre les incendies ainsi
que la sécurisation de la zone
vous l'avez rappelé une directive
européenne organise les contrôles et en
22 ans d'exploitation sous pavillon
italien
35 contrôle dans différents ports
européens ont été effectués sur ce
navire dont une fois à dunkerque en 2010
à chaque fois une autorisation a navigué
a été donné le dernier contrôle date du
26 octobre 2018 à hambourg en france de
réfection 1600 contrôle de ce type
bien sûr si l'anc est montré une erreur
manifeste il faudrait sévir nous en
sommes maintenant à contenir au maximum
cette catastrophe avec huit navires
actuellement sur zone et sept containers
c'est une mobilisation internationale
deux des navires ont été affrétés sous
l'égide de l'agencé européenne de
sécurité maritime
nous avons également un bateau espagnol
qui est là grâce à la coopération
bilatérale et des moyens mobilisés par
l'armateur nous suivons également la
pollution grâce à un système
satellitaire communautaire appelé klinsi
net une mise en demeure de l'armateur a
été fait pour mettre fin aux pollutions
par hydrocarbures par la pollution des
containers nous avons lancé une enquête
administrative judiciaire et technique
pour faire la lumière sur les
circonstances de l'accident et appeler
sa responsabilité
bien sûr en fonction des résultats de l'
enquête nous ferons les propositions
nécessaires au niveau européen pour
améliorer toujours plus la sécurité et
les réglementations
merci la parole est un monsieur philippe
pouillé pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues étant donnée la thématique de
la semaine ma question concerne la
francophonie mais en impro en but
j'aurais quand même vous dire que je
suis relativement marquée par l'absence
volontaire du premier ministre
aujourd'hui dans nos rangs voici un an
sous la coupole de l'institut de france
le prendre là à pully prononcer un
discours relatifs à la francophonie
après avoir partagé la conception de ce
qu'est aujourd'hui la francophonie c'est
à dire cette langue française devenue le
centre de toutes les nations et de tous
les peuples où elle fait souche dans sa
variété
le chef de l'état a fixé un cap
apprendre échanger et créer en français
outre ces engagements il s'est projeté
au-delà de nos frontières
il a souhaité que la france puisse à
travers son aide publique au
développement
réaffirmer son engagement fort pour
l'éducation à cet engagement en matière
de développement
le panda à public a également annoncé
des mesures concrètes notamment en
proposant un volontariat international
pour le français et un doublement des
missions du service civique sur cet
enjeu en annonçant un nouvel élan pour
les lycées français
un doublement du nombre d'élèves
inscrits dans le réseau scolaire d'ici
2025 et en demandant à nos
établissements du supérieur de
s'implanter hors de nos frontières et de
se regrouper en campus
l'ambition est importante il a également
ajouté de nouvelles missions aux acteurs
de l'audiovisuel francophone et à nombre
d'institutions qu'il faut aujourd'hui
partout dans le monde
vive la francophonie or à ce jour le
vantail internationale n'est toujours
pas mis en place les budgets alloués à
la fois aux alliances françaises et aux
lycées sont en diminution et
l'audiovisuel consacré la francophonie
est en plein doute
alors monsieur le ministre pouvez vous
nous dire un an après ce grand discours
quelles sont les actions du gouvernement
pour traduire les nombreux engagements
annoncés dans vos réponses
la parole est à monsieur jean baptiste
lemoyne secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre d'europe des affaires
étrangères vous avez la parole monsieur
le ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur mouillé je salue
également le vice président délégué de
la section française de l'assemblée
parlementaire de la francophonie je le
signale parce que ce sont les parlements
qui ont été pionniers avant les
gouvernements et nous avons fêté en 2017
et 50 ans de la pf alors un an après le
grand le discours fondateur
effectivement prononcé par le président
la république sous la coupole de
l'institut de france
et bien c'est un foisonnement
d'initiatives et d'actions qui ont vu le
jour
parlons moyens budgétaires nous sommes
passés tout simplement de 97 millions
d'euros octroyée au soutien au système
éducatif dans les pays en développement
parce que nous avons besoin pour que le
français soit une réalité non pas
seulement une potentialité et bien que
nous puissions accompagner ces systèmes
éducatifs un budget de 208 millions
d'euros en 2018 et nous allons la crotte
pour passer à 300 millions d'euros
par ailleurs il y à une synergie des
actions conduites aussi avec
l'organisation internationale de la
francophonie le président le public a pu
évoquer ces sujets hier en rencontrant
la nouvelle secrétaire générale madame
louise mushikiwabo et
tout cela va se décliner au sein des
institutions européennes pour que le
français soit toujours plus et mieux
enseigner aux fonctionnaires
internationaux parce que il est
essentiel pour que l'europe soit une
réalité également que le multilinguisme
soit une réalité concrète et qu'on
puisse s'y exprimer en français
s'agissant des volontaires
internationaux une idée qui avait
d'ailleurs été mis sur la table par
joëlle garriaud-maylam nous en sommes au
stade de l'expérimentation mais nous
entendons bien passé au stade de
l'industrialisation si je puis dire
ainsi
par ailleurs hier avec frédéric vidal
nous posions la première pierre d'une
maison des étudiants de la francophonie
au sein de la cité internationale
elle va pouvoir accueillir 150 étudiants
francophones en 2020 et ça sera un lieu
naturellement d'inspiration et puis vous
l'avez dit les campus
le campus franco-sénégalais le campus
franco tunisien tous ces chantiers
avancent bien et je sais que c'est un
sujet qui rassemble largement
j'ai d'ailleurs une pensée pour jacques
legendre et michel andré qui ont porté
haut cette flamme et que nous nous
attachons à perpétuer ensemble en
février mais celui né ce j'entends la
liste de dézinguer s'engager je reste en
tous les cas le témoin sur le terrain
dans des caisses de réelle entre les
discours et les cotisations alors nous
attendrons les mois qui viennent pour
voir la traduction d'une façon générale
je pense que même sous la coupole de
l'institut de france il pouffe avoir
avoir dit ce couple modeste mais des
engagements qu'ils soient tenues merci
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
jean françois husson pour le groupe
l'est républicain monsieur le sénateur
oui monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à madame emmanuelle wargon
ministre madame la ministre samedi
dernier dans le calme la bonne humeur et
une ambiance festive
près de quatre cent mille français dans
une univers une diversité d'âge de
conditions d'engagement associatif ou
politique ont manifesté pour que soit
revue à la hausse
l'ambition la france en matière
d'écologie au lendemain de la grève de
la jeunesse pour le climat fustigeant
dans les deux cas l'inaction du
gouvernement
je note que cela vous a laissé sans voix
et sans réaction
quand hier nicolas hulot claqué la porte
en regrettant la politique des petits
pas autrement dit l'immobilisme
madame la ministre les français vous
exhorte à agir aujourd'hui
pouvez vous donc nous dire quelle est
l'ambition du gouvernement sur votre
politique en faveur du climat et la
promotion d'une écologie positive plutôt
que punitive pour vous répondre la
parlait là madame la secrétaire d'état
auprès de lui de la transition
écologique et la ministre monsieur le
président du sénat mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur russe on vous avait
cité la mobilisation des jeunes et la
mobilisation de nos concitoyens pour le
climat vous avez bien fait parce que ces
mobilisations sont salutaires et elles
sont importantes
nous avons besoin d'une prise de
conscience nous avons besoin d'une
volonté commune pour agir et pousser au
maximum la transformation écologique et
solidaire dont notre pays a besoin et
dont d'ailleurs le monde entier a besoin
ces marches sont importantes de même que
les débats qui ont eu lieu et je pense
au débat qui a eu lieu avec le président
de la république à gréoux les bains avec
de nombreux jeunes qui ont été également
interpellé le président en la matière et
demain nous rencontrerons avec jean
michel blanquer françois de rugy brune
poirson et gabriela talent des lycéens
qui ont participé aussi à des débats
dans leur établissement
il ne s'agit pas d'être interpellé les
uns contre les autres il ne s'agit pas
d'être opposés les uns aux autres il
s'agit ensemble d'agir pour cette
transformation écologique au ministère
de la transition écologique nous sommes
à la tâche tous les jours nous n'avons
pas attendu ces mobilisations pour agir
nous sommes déterminés nous avançons en
matière énergétique
la prèze la bonne programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie a été
présenté récemment en 2020 fermeront les
deux premiers réacteurs nucléaires en
france
à fessenheim nous avons signé le projet
de territoire d'ici 2022 fermeront les
quatre centrales à charbon qui reste en
métropole cette transition et est en
cours elle est faite avec les
territoires que nous accompagnons nous
créons l'office français de la
biodiversité en matière de biodiversité
nous mettons en place le onzième parc
naturel nous partageons mieux la
ressource en eau à travers les assises
de l'eau nous sommes à la tâche tous les
jours et sur l'économie circulaire nous
avons présenté une feuille de route de
l'économie circulaire qui va également
nous permettre d'être ambitieux en la
matière et cette feuille de route
arrivera prochainement devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat le
président de la république l'a dit à gré
où il faut aller plus vite plus loin
plus fort ce sera aussi l'enjeu de la
sortie du grand débat que de proposer
une feuille de route complémentaire pour
être au rendez-vous de la transition
écologique et solidaire
merci la médiation réponses convenues
madame la ministre je le dis très
simplement le gouvernement reste petit
bras un moment où en fait vous avez
affaire un dossier pour le moins
préoccupant et il ne faut surtout pas
geler les ambitions en plein
réchauffement climatique je vais vous
donner quelques exemples la ppe
maintes fois repoussé dont on peine à
voir une ligne directrice la trajectoire
carbone pour le moins indécise le
développement des énergies alternatives
balbutiant la sortie du nucléaire aussi
peu sereine que le dossier de fermeture
des centrales à charbon depuis la
fiscalité verte mais sous le tapis
depuis la crise de gilet jaune et qui
risque de demeurer longtemps à maquiller
ou se cachent mécontentement injustice
et colère madame la ministre
une action écologique c'est aussi 100
milliards par an consacrés au traitement
de la pollution de l'air la facture
énergétique ces 40 milliards de déficit
c'est à dire deux tiers du déficit du
commerce extérieur
alors faites confiance à vos partenaires
les collectivités territoriales
auxquelles je vous offre une belle
occasion de proposer sans délai une
nouvelle grande ou impact 2 un plan
d'action pour le climat est la
transition écologique
madame la ministre il est temps d'agir
ou jupiter
rist de risque de devenir et hall le
dieu du vent merci
[Applaudissements]
le prochaine question d'actualité auront
lieu le mardi 26 mars à 16h45
je vais juste part de l'océan se sera
reprise à 16h20 pour la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi d'orientation
des mobilités séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement et on peut dire
que la guerre institutionnel est
déclarée entre le gouvernement et le
sénat puisque le premier ministre
edouard philippe a volontairement
boycotté cette séance de questions
d'actualité du sénat à cause de la
décision ce matin du bureau du sénat de
signaler à la justice le cas du
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
patrick strzoda suspectés de faux
témoignage devant la commission d'
enquête sur la sphère benalla est
également de transmettre les
déclarations des deux hauts
fonctionnaires de l'elysée alexis colère
et le général lavernhe edouard philippe
qui a appelé le président du sénat
gérard larcher pour justifier son
boycott
et cette absence elle est très mal
passée auprès des sénateurs cet après
midi qui ont copieusement hué tous les
ministres qui sont venus répondre à
leurs questions les sénateurs
socialistes ont même tapé du poing sur
leur table en criant il est où il est où
à propos du premier ministre qui était
absent c'est dire si l'ambiance était
électrique cet après-midi dans
l'hémicycle alors qu'on a appris au même
moment que le président de l'assemblée
nationale à richard ferrand avait annulé
sa participation demain à une conférence
devant les étudiants de sciences po
lille qu'il devait animer avec le
président du sénat gérard larcher une
conférence sur la démocratie
parlementaire
un boycott aux mêmes motifs de la
décision du bureau du sénat
dans la sphère benalla on peut donc dire
que cette affaire benalla a réduit à
néant les relations entre d'un côté le
gouvernement et l'assemblée et de
l'autre le sénat merci beaucoup
alexandre pour toutes vos précisions et
on continue à les réactions justement
avec vous au tam tran huy avec le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
aux maires craignent cette boutade oui
marc fesneau et bien à votre réaction
tout d'abord à ce boycott questions
d'actualité par le premier ministre
edouard philippe est également
l'annulation du déplacement en commun
que devait avoir lieu entre gérard à
l'archet et richard ferrand demain à
lille j'ai pas de réaction particulière
à avoir le premier ministre a appelé le
président larcher pour lui donner les
motifs de son absence s'est défait
normaux dans la vie parlementaire on va
pas non plus et du corps et les choses
par ailleurs richard âge quand même
rien que ça c'est très bien mais je
pense que c'est bien qu'il ya un
dialogue direct entre le premier
ministre et le président de l'assemblée
nationale ou du sénat pour expliquer ce
que sont les faits est-ce que ce qu'ils
peuvent être des déclarations ou des
décisions qui peuvent poser question en
tout cas l'exécutif ou à d'autres la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire quand
même au passage chez moi je suis un
ministre des relations avec le parlement
qui par fonction mais aussi par
construction des convictions croit
vraiment à l'utilité du bicamérisme et
donc vous ne trouverez pas à remettre en
cause le sénat dans sa fonction et dans
son utilité
le bureau après une décision j'en prends
acte reconnaissons aussi en tout cas
beaucoup d'observateurs le dise que
c'était une décision de nature politique
il faut simplement que le sénat
l'assument comme une décision politique
d'ailleurs elle est intéressante à
double titre cet intérêt un procès
politique
en tout cas je viens juste une décision
sur fondement politique d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant de voir qui a voté cette
décision manifestement les républicains
le parti socialiste qui dans une
collusion intéressantes du moment a fait
qu'ils ont pris cette décision et pour
le reste je voudrais dire deux choses
moi je me réfère à ce qu'a dit le
président marseille qui est membre de la
majorité qui est un membre influent et
solide de la majorité qui a dit cette
décision elle est superfétatoire elle
est fragile elle est injustifiée ça me
parait détails sur les âmes en clair oui
mais les membres de la majorité dont il
est moins suspect par construction
d'être comment dirais-je influencé par
tel ou tel il a dit des choses très
clair je pense qu hervé marseille parle
de réseaux wifi dernier point on est
dans un moment où je pense que les
français ont besoin que les assemblées
fonctionne que les assemblées
fonctionnent ensemble et je suis pas sûr
que ce genre les affaires entre jussieu
la décision a abaissé par le moment mais
je suis rassure que ce type de décision
où ce genre de procès politique qui
peuvent être intentées à tel ou tel
permettent d'aider rehausser le niveau
du débat public et le débat politique et
je suis sûr que la raison va revenir ce
que cette maison que je connais bien est
une maison qui normalement travail avec
raison et dans la volonté de l'intérêt
collectif je crois que les français nous
attendent sur l'interprétation est mal
parti n'apparaît au ces le le sepa
richard ferrand dont je vous parle oui
non j'ai l'argent qui nous est très
amère que mon propos je vous dis que
dans un moment comme ça on n'a pas
besoin de décisions qui soient des
traditions qui manifestement sondés sur
des fondements politiques ça ne concerne
pas richard ferrand ça concerne plutôt
la décision du bureau ce matin
d'accord merci beaucoup marqué nous
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci à
vous tam pour cette réaction et
françoise laborde a rejoint sur ce
plateau au bonsoir c'est un truc à des
sols de la haute garonne
bien que cette absence du premier
ministre mesures de rétorsion au vote du
bureau du sénat
ce matin fait beaucoup réagir vous le
regrettez alors oui je vais dire que je
le regrette parce que bon j'ai entendu
les propos de marc fesneau en disant que
peut-être le sénat ne sort pas grandie
mais dans ces cas là moi je dis que mort
si le premier ministre n'est pas là non
plus je pourrais dire aussi que le
gouvernement ne sort pas grandie donc ça
c'est de la politique politicienne comme
je n'aime pas après sur le choix du
bureau
il est exact moi je n'ai pas participé
puisque je n'étais pas membre de cette
commission spéciale donc je suis allé à
quelques auditions comme tout le monde
sur le choix final je pense que l'on
peut comprendre l'aspect parce qu'on ne
ment pas à une commission denquête donc
les deux personnes messieurs bennama
écrase soit disons un peu plus mis en
avant est peut-être cette déclaration la
justice ne me choque pas pour laure s
est une suspicion de faux témoignages et
voilà je mets des points de suspension
je ne suis pas membre du bureau
donc je vois en effet ce que dit marc
raynaud ce que disent d'autres personnes
c'est peut-être une façon aussi de se
dire qu'on n'a pas choisi le bon moment
mais on ne choisit jamais le moment de
la fin d'une commission denquête ça
tombe mal avec les réformes
constitutionnelles qui arrive et ce
serait dommage qu'il y ait une guerre
alors que le bicamérisme est tellement
important voilà donc les choses bon
voilà une question une série et une
séance de questions d'actualité un peu
houleuse
j'ose espérer que chacun retrouvera ses
esprits et remettra au niveau car
richard deschamps qu'il devait se rendre
demain devant les étudiants de sciences
po à lille avec le président du sénat
gérard larcher a lui aussi décidé bien
d'annuler de boycotter à cette
conférence il dit on ne veut pas d'un
côté abaissé le parlement et vouloir le
promouvoir au
la commission denquête n'était pas à
l'assemblée bien sûr puisqu'elle est à
majorité la république en marche
je pense qu'il y aurait eu notre époque
un homme voilà je crois qu'il ne faut
pas non plus dire bon nous on n'aurait
pas fait comme ça chacun va chez soi
avant le président afférents il y a eu
quelques soucis à l'assemblée son
prédateur pas son prédécesseur mais du
temps d'avant jeux bien à barcelone
voilà entre monsieur bartolone et
monsieur larcher n'étaient pas tous les
jours facile non plus donc je pense que
justement si on veut respecter le
bicamérisme et continuer à construire
il va falloir que la vapeur retombe
et puis qu'on recommence à travailler
alors on continue à bien cette émission
et on repasse par la salle à des
conférences où nous attend et à mme tran
huy avec un des coûts rapporteur de
cette commission dont quelques
parlementaires le fossé jean pierre
sueur jean-pierre sur votre réaction au
boycott d'edouard philippe de la séance
de questions d'actualité bien sûr lié à
la décision du bureau du sénat de ce
matin également richard ferrand qui
annule son déplacement commun qui était
prévue demain avec gérard larcher si
c'est un boycott de la part du premier
ministre c'est incompréhensible et le
fait que le président de l'assemblée
nationale renonce à rencontrer gérard
larcher est tout à fait incompréhensible
le président de l'assemblée nationale
devrait défendre le contrôle
parlementaire
qu'est ce que nous avons fait nous avons
fait un rapport
c'est pas de la faute au sénat si
monsieur benalla s'est comporté comme il
s'est comparé mais ce n'est pas de la
faute sénat s'il y a eu tous les
dysfonctionnements induits
et si on les a laissés faire c'est pas
la faute au sénat si de hauts
personnages ont menti devant une
commission d' enquête parlementaire il
est toujours oui mais aujourd'hui nous
tirons les conséquences de cela
conformément à la constitution et
puisque monsieur le premier ministre par
tellement de la séparation des pouvoirs
il devrait être très respectueux
de la séparation des pouvoirs nous
parlementaires nous faisons notre
travail tel qu'il est prévu dans la
constitution
mécha ferrand qui parle de fins
politiciennes dans la saison il abaisse
le parlement qui a bercé par la cie cela
fait tort puisque moi je n'ai pas fait
ce travail en tant que membre d'un parti
politique mais en tant que parlementaire
chargée avec mes collègues par la
constitution de contrôler le pouvoir
exécutif est d'évaluer les politiques
publiques points est ce que c'est une
crise politique ouverte pour vous une
salle on sent qu'on n'avait pas vu
certains ouvrent une crise politicienne
c'est leur problème
moi je dis que dans cette affaire nous
nous intéressons à la vérité aux droits
et à la loi merci merci jean grâce à
pour votre réaction
merci beaucoup autant pour 7 à nouvelle
réaction est ce que vous racontez
françoise laborde et bien qu'il y ait
des conséquences sur la révision des
institutions le sénat qui a pu me
braquer à l'elysée par ce vote du bureau
qui pourrait en faire les frais à lors
de la prochaine révision
constitutionnelle c'est un souci quelque
bien sûr c'est ce que je vous ai dit je
pense que cela ne pouvait pas plus mal
tomber
mais je crois aussi en l'intelligence
des uns et des autres parce que les
modifications constitutionnelles des
institutions ne se font pas pour un jour
pour deux jours où après une crise c'est
quand même quelque chose qui va engager
notre pays pour des années il ya des
choses qui étaient déjà engagés
certaines ont été arrêtés du fait du
grand débat parce qu'on voulait savoir
aussi un petit peu ce qui allait se dire
sur nos territoires
donc moi je crois quand même ont
l'intelligence personnelle de chaque
individu qui va participer à ces
réformes institutionnelles ça pourrait
avoir un impact sur la question de la
réduction du nombre de parlementaires ça
pourrait faire l'objet d'âpres
négociations à présent entre emmanuelle
le maquereau et gérard larcher
ça peut ça peu puisqu'en c'est que il y
avait eu des avancées sur les
territoires garder un certain nombre de
sénateur ou de député dans les
territoires ruraux pour que justement il
ne se retrouve pas complètement
déshabillés on le dit au niveau du sénat
certains disent que le sénat est trop
représentés au niveau du rural
bon vous savez bien que les textes de
loi sont quand même fait autour des
urbains il faut le dire
après bien sûr on pense à nos
territoires donc c'est quand même le
rôle des sénateurs et nous avons quand
même aussi tous les territoires
outre-mer
parce que quand on vote une loi c'est
pour tous n'est pas seulement pour la
métropole et je dirais plutôt urbaine
donc j'espère voilà que les uns et les
autres vont se dire nous travaillons
pour notre pays ce n'est pas facile pas
aujourd'hui que je vais vous le dire
avec tout ce qui se passe donc il faut
garder la tête froide et j'espère que
chacun après quelques jours de folie et
peut-être lille s'était pourtant dans
son rôle avec cette commission d'
enquête parlementaire
c'est ce que je vous ai dit pour moi la
commission denquête c'est quelque chose
d'important
vous le savez on on jure chaque fois de
dire la vérité toute la vérité j'ai mené
une commission denquête donc je sais ce
que c'est c'est pour ça que par rapport
aux 2
je pense qu'il ne fallait surtout pas
laisser passer sans craindre la merci
j'ai senti que c'était un peu plus
compliqué pour les trois autres
personnes
pourquoi on a gardé monsieur jeu trop
d'à pourquoi on n'a pas gardé les autres
c'est vrai que la justice va faire son
travail donc un moment le sénat va se
retirer et la querelle et où la montée
un peu de colère où va s'arrêter puisque
la justice va faire son travail
bien sûr ce n'était jamais arrivé ou
alors il faut que je sais pas il faut
remonter ce n'était jamais arrivé donc
une commission denquête si on veut que
la commission denquête garde son rôle de
contrôle dans le cadre du bicamérisme
que je vous dis on pourra en reparler
peut-être dans quelques temps quand
l'assemblée aura une commission denquête
affaire on peut pas exiger des gens donc
nous auditionnons d'avoir une honnêteté
totale puisqu'ils jure
devant le président et les membres de la
commission et d'un autre côté dire non
mais c'est pas grave
donc ça s'est trouvée alors après qu'ils
aient de la surenchère
je ne ferai pas de commentaire vous me
connaissez
ouais on va continuer cet entretien on
repasse par la salle des conférences
pour une nouvelle réaction
avec gérard longuet sénateur et ancien
ministre il est avec vous ou tel produit
oui gérard longuet votre réaction au
fait que l'on ait appris qu' edouard
philippe a donc boycotté la séance de
questions d'actualité au sénat également
que richard ferrand annuler demain son
déplacement commun qui était prévu avec
gérard larcher tout cela en réaction à
la décision qui a été prise par le
bureau du sénat
ce sont des gamineries qui ne sont pas à
la hauteur de la responsabilité de ses
hommes le premier ministre le président
de l'assemblée nous avons une
constitution de 58 qui fait du parlement
assemblée nationale et sénat des
pouvoirs autonome
nous ne sommes pas nous sénateurs les
employés de l'exécutif
qu'on soit de gauche au consulat droite
nous sommes dans notre fonction de
contrôler le gouvernement
alors c'est pas toujours agréable d'être
contrôlé il se trouve que
malheureusement il ya une suspicion de
faux témoignages qui ne veut pas dire
d'ailleurs une certitude de faux
témoignages que nous avions aussi des
lobes l'obligation le bureau du sénat
avait l'obligation comme le l'ancien
article 40 du code de procédure pénale
de transmettre au parquet pour qu'il
examine et on verra bien ce que le
parquet dira richard ferrand qui dans un
communiqué juge que cela a été fait à
des fins politiciennes qui abaisse le
parlement il ne mâche pas ses mots le
présente à son âme il est parfaitement
hors de son de son rôle
il devrait au contraire se réjouir de
l'indépendance du parlement vis-à-vis de
l'exécutif
je respecte l'exécutif mais l'exécutif
doit respecter lui aussi les lois et
nous sommes là parlementaires députés et
sénateurs y sont que les députés sont
traditionnellement d'un camp ou d'un
autre
peut-être moins libre et moins
disponibles pour contrôler nous nous
sommes libres nous sommes des sénateurs
nous ne devons pas notre élections à
l'exécutif
et nous disons très clairement qu'il y à
une suspicion
eu d'infraction pas de violation de la
déclaration sous serment
voilà et c'est un procès politique dont
l'issue était déjà écrite d'avancé dit
la république en marche le sénat et ont
des connections les mots sont très durs
du côté bien sûr de la majorité
présidentielle je crois que cette
commission des lois qui a été publique
et dont les qui a été très écouté par
nos compatriotes montre que le président
de la commission des lois philippe bas
s'est comporté avec beaucoup de mesure
avec jean pierre sueur ils ont posés
l'un et l'autre des questions
extrêmement précise le journal
naturellement muriel et ciblée tout
l'erreur c'est que l'exécutif manque
d'expérience politique est à oublier
simplement que l'assemblée comme le
sénat sont des organes indépendants
voulue par le peuple pour contrôler
l'exécutif
en tout cas les faits c'est que là on
est devant en plein dans une crise
politique n'est pas une grille verte
au contraire moi je trouve ça très bon
je trouve que c'est un rappel à l'ordre
chacun doit faire son métier et
l'exécutif doit respecter le législatif
ce qu'ils avaient tendance à oublier et
ce n'est pas le premier à l'oublier mais
la révision constitutionnelle n'a jamais
était bien engagée mais là c'est pire
que tout dans cette merde j'ai presque
envie de dire que on revient aux
fondamentaux at on le droit de contrôler
y compris des choses désagréables
la réponse est oui moi j'ai commencé
jeune parlementaire à partie être
rapporteur d'une commission denquête
pour renvoyer
tenez vous bien en cour de justice le
ministre d'état ministre de l'intérieur
et bien j'ai fait ce travail avec mes
collègues de gauche et de droite
ce travail d' enquête en toute liberté
on n'a jamais considéré que c'était une
crise c'est simplement le fonctionnement
des institutions
personne dans notre pays n'est à l'abri
d'un contrôle et l'exécutif pas plus
merci beaucoup gérard longuet d'avoir
répondu à mes questions
merci à vous grillot a également réagi à
cette séance de questions d'actualité
notamment sur l'absence est assez inédit
au parlement lors d'une séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement du
premier ministre philippe écoutez nous
on a un immense respect pour
l'institution sénatoriales
qui si j'en crois les voix qui s'élèvent
y compris sur les bancs du sénat s'est
abîmé dans cette affaire plutôt qu'elle
ne s'est renforcé et donc voilà s'il ya
des décisions politiques et que le sénat
a fait de
au fond cette affaire une
instrumentalisation politique et nous on
est trop regardants est trop attachée à
l'institution sénatoriales pour ne pas
marquer aussi notre désaccord lorsqu'il
ya un désaccord et on peut considérer
que raisonnablement il ya assez peu de
respect dans la décision qui a été
rendue par le bureau du sénat et dont je
le redis
beaucoup de sénateurs s'émeuvent de la
décision qui a été prise
vous y voyez vous une lecture politique
françoise laborde à ce que le sénat
finalement instrumentalisés cette
commission denquête à cette saisine de
la justice ce matin pour atteindre le
chef de l'état
alors ça je ne le dirai pas parce que
n'étant pas membre du bureau et n'ayant
pas participé à tout le travail de fond
parce que je sais que valérie létard a
fait quand même un gros travail sur ce
sujet puisque c'était la vice-présidente
chargée de présenter un certain nombre
d'arguments
bon on est sûr j'ai lu le rapport comme
beaucoup de personnes parce que c'était
quand même intéressant alors ce qui est
peut-être politique c'est que
l'assemblée nationale donc prennent
partie alors qu'ils sont oserais-je dire
au même niveau que nous quand on
considère que nous sommes dans le cas du
législatif et le gouvernement c'est
l'exécutif donc à ce niveau là peut-être
qu'il y en ait fait un choix difficile
après que le premier ministre ne soit
pas venu aujourd'hui c'est son problème
c'est sa responsabilité
je ne sais pas si c'est le président de
la république qui lui a dit ou s'il
était d'accord
voilà il ya déjà des choses on ne peut
pas créer des événements politiques
quand on ne sait pas vraiment le plus
grave disait bruno retailleau ce serait
que cela donne un pousse à penser par
donc on fait payer les lampistes et qu
on exonère les autres en ciblant d'un
côté et bien deux poids deux mesures
recours vincent kraz alexandre benalla
et les collaborateurs proches de
l'elysée alors je n'ai entendu bon je
suis pas sûr que les deux premiers donc
messieurs benalla iqra soit des
lampistes et c'est quand même un peu
voilà je pense qu'ils ont des niveaux
quand on voit l'importance je dirais de
monsieur b nana je ne les jamais
considéré comme un lampiste
donc bon mais je vous dis ben qu'il ait
dit cela c'était justement peut-être
pour justifier le choix qu au départ lui
il voulait que les cinq soit donc après
va de nouveau différent puisqu'il ya le
parquet apparemment si un peu plus
compliqué que cela
moi je ne considère pas voilà je trouve
ce sont des jugements alors je veux pas
dire des jugements de valeur mais là
aussi quoi sont des mots il faut faire
attention aux mots que l'on utilise un
brest avec nous et françoise laborde
puisque on évoquait justement valérie
létard 1 qui a donc présenté ce matin
son rapport au bureau elle était au
micro de plein traduit les quelques
instants écouter
oui valérie létard pourriez-vous nous
dire exactement ce que vous avez
préconisé au sein de votre rapport et
bien tout d'abord rappelé que
conformément à ce que le président du
sénat souhaitées on a présenté un
rapport qui était posée en termes
juridiques en termes de droit en
rappelant point par point et on va dire
sujet après sujet demande après demande
sur quoi on se fonder juridiquement pour
saisir le ministère public et donc nous
avons essayé de présenter ce rapport
donc en droit suite à la lettre de
saisine du président bat un qui
présidait la commission denquête et
trois catégories en fait on nous avons
distingué en trois niveaux la saisine en
tout cas la transmission ministère
public tout d'abord les personnes pour
lesquelles nous considérons que les
éléments qui permettent de fonder une
suspicion pour faux témoignages étaient
réunis établi mains sales draps un effet
de vases monsieur benalla et de monsieur
strzoda pour la partie mission démission
de monsieur benalla comète vous mettez
d'ailleurs patrick strzoda au même
niveau que vincent crasé alexandre bédat
la suspicion de faux témoignages à
combes et ces personnes au même niveau
c'est que nous on nous interroge sur la
grande question de l'article 6 de
l'ordonance qui en fait permet de
caractériser en délit toute personne qui
a fait un faux témoignage alors qu'il a
prêté serment devant une commission
denquête il s'agit pas de la faire on
juge pas la faire on essaye de
déterminer qui est suspect de faux
témoignages suspect une tranche ont pas
nous sommes pas juges une transmutation
la saison thermale qui décidera si oui
ou non
donc les trois premiers ensuite nous
avons une deuxième catégorie où nous
avons instruit
effectivement selon les éléments qu'il
faut donner
conformément à la jurisprudence un
certain nombre d'éléments sont
identifiés mais ils ne sont pas
suffisants pour considérer qu'il ya une
suspicion de faux témoignages avéré à ce
stade c'est à dire que là aussi nous
transmettons à la justice sans
considérer qu'il ya suspicion de faux
témoignages avéré à ce stade nous n'en
avons pas tous les éléments
alexis kohler et lionel lavergne il
s'agit de monsieur colère de monsieur la
verte et monsieur tron a pour les autres
éléments qui apparaissent dans le
rapport
et enfin et vous transmettez tout de
même nous nous transmettons mais nous
transmettant disons que tous les
éléments n'étaient pas réunis pour qu à
ce stade et que le bureau signal en fait
et saisissent la justice pour suspicion
de faux témoignages nous n'avions pas
nous considérons ne pas avoir tous les
éléments et enfin nous transmettons
conformément à la lettre de philippe bas
les éléments qui sont figurer en annexe
du rapport et qui sont transmis à la
justice pour qu'elle puisse le cas
échéant pousser les investigations est
allé plus loin dans la procédure si
elles le jugent utile
voilà pour cette réaction de valérie
létard françoise laborde rapidement le
sénat a su faire preuve de son
indépendance dans cette affaire oui là
je suis obligé de dire oui bien sûr on
est d'accord on n'est pas d'accord
certains vous avez vu bon de toute façon
il ya eu un vote ce matin et toutes les
voies n'ont pas été pour
mais là dessus on est d'accord c'est à
dire que l'indépendance du sénat il ya
une procédure en abouti à un résultat je
pense que valérie létard a très bien
expliqué entre ce qui était suspicion de
faux témoignage faux témoignage peut
être vraiment avéré bon donc elle
explique très bien donc l'indépendance
du sénat est totale bien merci merci à
vous françoise laborde d'avoir participé
à cette émission avant de se quitter on
retourne dans l'hémicycle puisque et
bien l'absence du premier ministre
continue de faire parler les sénateurs à
part des rappels au règlement alexandre
ponsard
louis a fini puisque les sénateurs
devaient comment continuer à examiner la
loi sur les mobilités mais le sénateur
socialiste jean pierre sueur a fait un
rappel au règlement concernant ce
boycott du premier ministre décédé et
séance de questions d'actualité
concernant également la décision de
richard ferrand d'annuler sa visite à
sciences po lille avec gérard larcher il
a trouvé ces décisions inquiétante et il
a demandé au gouvernement de respecter
le contrôle du parlement qui est
garantie par la constitution
merci beaucoup alexandre pour toutes ces
précisions c'est la fin de cette édition
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 on
voit plus loin présenté par rebecca
fitoussi très bonne suite des programmes
sont excellents
[Musique]